the press so I'd like to begin by
thanking the organizers for sending and
very happy and I'm here to give you a
round up on some recent activities in
selective inference which are centered
around construction of interval and
point estimates so this is part one of
the tutorial and my goal here is
threefold
in nature first I want to give you like
examples which will probably and
hopefully motivate you as a data curator
to understand that some of these tools
of selective inference that I talked
about today can be deployed if you
really ever want to combine some of your
exploratory findings with a confirmatory
analysis second I want to start talking
about a cutting-edge application in
genomics where I'd applied selective
inferential tools to get effect size
estimates post data mining so my goal
here is not really to tell you about the
application that I've worked on but
rather to tell you that there can be
many more useful such applications where
we can use conditional inference to
enhance our understanding in those
communities and thirdly I would start by
talking about some first approaches
which are aligned along a conditional
perspective to selective inference
hopefully tell you what are their
shortcomings and how we have overcome
them and where are we right now
currently so to start with we all know
that knife inference or classical
inferential regime starts with the basic
assumption that the analyst always knew
the small set of variables that mattered
from thousands of noisy variables but
like we have that understanding so far
that this is far from reality and in
reality what we do is once we have the
data the analysts explores the data to
find some meaningful structure in it
and that's when if he wants to calibrate
the effect sizes of those discovered
findings he would need some sort of
selective inferential tools to come to
his rescue because no longer classical
inference will give you the guarantees
that you want to have so selective
inference is a broad field that tries to
blend in confirmatory enough exploratory
analysis with the confirmatory paradigm
and like I said it's a pretty broad term
and there are different lines of work
that aim at different sorts of
guarantees depending on what your goal
is at the end of the day so let me start
with a toy example so you have a
response why to begin with which is
n-dimensional and being the number of
samples you have you have some
predictors a set of P predictors to be
precise measured for your n samples
recorded in your predictor matrix X you
run save our favorite lasso query coming
from the Sequoia Hall to find some set
of predictors which hopefully explain
the variance in this response Y and you
now want to report inference for the
active coefficients that lasso gave you
as an output so let's see a concrete
example so I'm giving you the data
generative mechanism say for instance
here n is 500 so I have 500 samples my P
is a hundred I generate X as a matrix
with Gaussian entries with covariance
given by this covariance matrix that has
correlation parameter 0.2 I generate my
response as just noise which is
completely independent of the predictor
matrix it is it has nothing to do with
matrix X I just run lasso at a fixed
value of lambda typically I take this
lambda to be a theoretical value of
lambda that gets you can see
distant selection so this is the active
set of coefficients that I see from
lasso and lasso shrinks some other
coefficients to 0 now say I want to get
inference one way is that
now once lasso has given me this active
set of coefficients I refit a linear
model to the selected subspace of X and
my response Y so I run an OLS depend
based on X Y and Y so what would be my
knife point estimators so my knife point
estimator is the OLS estimate which is
just this and what our knife confidence
intervals here so now if on fidence
intervals could be just centered around
the OLS estimator and scaled by the
variance so if I report a confidence
interval for the Jade coefficient of
this of a selected target then it's
centered around the corresponding jet
coordinate of the OLS estimator and the
variance is just a scale of XE prime X e
inverse the diagonals AJ the diagonal
entry of this matrix is just OLS like
regular estimate point estimation in
classical inference where we know that
these naive intervals are happen to be
Gaussian now see you repeat this
experiment 50 different times and you
construct your intervals based on this
algorithm that I told you right now and
you assess the coverage of your
intervals for these reported targets
that I told you and you'll see that the
ninth coverage is just 30%
so this is not a phenomenon which is
restricted to the setting where there is
all noise but if you even put some
signal say now I simulate my y
conditional on X with some signals I
have five true signals and I vary the
SNR and I look at the coverage of these
intervals I repeat the experiment in the
similar fashion it's just my data
generative mechanism is now different in
the sense that I have some signals in my
model still the coverage is pretty bad
so nice sorry
SNR is the signal-to-noise ratio and it
is computed as basically if beta is your
vector of is your true vector of signals
then its beta prime beta by the noise
noise is your one over Sigma yes and
this is related to proportion of
variance explained as I think SNR by one
plus SNR is proportion of variance
explained so this is this is very low
proportions of variance explained 0.5
corresponds to around 0.5 by 1 plus 0.5
which is one third of the variance
explained so my goal here is to talk
about getting valid confidence intervals
and hopefully I'll move to point
estimation in the second part of the
tutorial so the first question here is
that ok our classical guarantees of
coverage to fail us so how do we fi
redefine guarantees for coverage
post-selection
and there have been two directions of
work that have mainly focused on
providing valid confidence intervals
post-selection one is the simultaneous
guarantee rating back to the posi paper
in 2013 which gives you a control on the
proportion of reported intervals that
don't cover the true underlying
parameter
and that's control at some alpha but the
challenge here is of course in
determining these confidence intervals
how do you construct these confidence
intervals and the way they construct the
confidence intervals it's in a very
general fashion in the sense that these
confidence intervals actually hold for
any selection procedure so if you you
don't have to tell these statistician
what selection you really did on your
data to get these confidence intervals
but as you can imagine that this
generality also comes at a huge cost of
power so these intervals happen to be
very long and the second issue is
tractability so I don't think there has
been much progress since this paper in
making this method really useful so that
people can use it so it's these
confidence intervals cannot be
constructed for really like even
regression dimensions greater than 30 if
I remember I don't know if I've they've
made some progress in increasing it
further but like I know at least for
real problems you cannot construct these
confidence intervals so the second
perspective that I'm going to focus on
is the conditional perspective to
selective inference which has been I
think introduced more in these papers
little and video nettle where the
guaranty you look at is the proportion
of intervals that do not cover the two
underlying parameter conditioned on the
selection event so you try to control
that rate I'll talk about this guarantee
in slightly more details slide later but
as you can see like to construct these
confidence intervals you need to tell
the statistician what selection you
apply to your data so this perspective
is quite tailored for the selection
process that resulted in you observing
this active set of coefficients but at
the same time it's more powerful and
also tractable more tractable than the
posi paper of berkutov and i'll tell you
more about how we have use some of these
procedures to a real-life application
where we have
a regression dimensions in the order of
millions so as you can see the main
difference one is of course the
simultaneous guarantee of the posi paper
is more general you construct the
confidence intervals without even
knowing what selection you apply to the
data whereas in the conditional
perspective you really need to prescribe
what selection you did on your data but
I don't view it in a negative sense
because I feel like if you really want
inference with some reasonable part at
the end of the day the least I deserve
to know is what you did with the data so
you have to understand what really tools
what tools you used to explore your data
and you just have to tell me what you
did tell you what I did it sounds simple
but it might not be at times what are
you gonna do with that so what does it
mean to tell you what I did and how is
that special yeah so here I think so far
still we know need to know explicitly
the selection procedure that you did on
your data now when you say implicit you
also have to tell me what you really
mean by implicit like are you still
concealing me from from me some part of
the selection that you did but so far I
think whatever we are doing is based on
the exact selection that you applied to
the data so you have to tell me what all
you did to explore across your data
use the program to do my selection I can
hand you that I mean you just have to
maybe describe to me what that program
is like you have to like in the case of
lasso you just described to me okay you
ran a lasso algorithm so you have to
tell me what algorithm you ran so that
has in some sense a closed form that's
independent of how I actually do it okay
in principle yes it might be hard to
carry out we just needed so we have to
be able to describe the event on the
defend that stuff subset of the sample
space that corresponds to make
commencing selection that helps thank
you
so the other selective inferential
guarantee that we have heard in this
workshop and all of you are aware about
is false discovery rate but I want to
tell you that it's a very different
selective inferential guarantee to me
there is a long line of work that has
produced different methods that try and
control defaults discovery rate but for
me FDR is really a guarantee on
selection and like Kiara put it
yesterday in her talk it's it's more
sort of a principal way of doing your
exploratory analysis where you get
findings which have some guarantees but
you still want to investigate them
further it's not a confirmatory analysis
exactly and I'm going to talk about the
second part more so so even if you have
a procedure that really guarantees you
FDR on selection you are ultimately at
the end of the day have some findings
that you want to investigate further it
doesn't you cannot like if you still try
to construct confidence intervals using
classical methods you do not get the
coverage guarantee so FDR guarantee
doesn't really give you coverage
guarantees if you are going with the
confirmatory analysis and now let's look
at the conditional coverage guarantee a
little more closely so this was the
guarantee that I showed you on the slide
before so what does this mean explicitly
so if I try and construct 90% confidence
intervals in the conditional regime then
I expect at max 10% of them to not cover
the two underlying parameter when
conditioned upon the selective upon the
selection event and this is what is
dubbed as selective false coverage rate
control in fillion at all
so this guarantee is what we call a
selective FCR and selective FC are also
implies control of PFC R which in turn
implies control of FC R now let me just
define what FC r and PFC R are just in
case people are not aware of them so FC
r has been
in this paper by Benjamin E and
yackinelli it's the proportion of
intervals that do not cover the two
underlying parameter amongst the
reported intervals so you report a
certain number of intervals after your
selection event it's the proportion of
intervals that don't cover the two
underlying parameter and PFC R is
nothing but FCR because FC r this
quantity might not make sense when you
report nothing when mod E is actually
zero so PFC R is just FC r conditioned
on the fact that you report at least
something that mod E is greater than
zero and you can clearly see very
trivially that FC r is actually PFC R
times the property that should report
something now just maybe a little slide
to show you that selective FC r does
imply control of PFC R so it's a more
stringent control so if you do control
selective FC r you end up controlling
PFC R and you end end up controlling FC
r as well so so we start with the
definition of PFC our like I said it's
the proportion of intervals reported
intervals that don't cover the two
underlying parameter conditioned on the
fact that you report something if we use
the tower property of expectation and
condition it on the selection event then
what this turns out to be the sum of the
probabilities that the jth coordinate of
the jape confidence interval doesn't
cover the two underlying parameter
condition upon selection and this is
what this conditional inference tries to
control so it controls this quantity at
level alpha so if you do control this
quantity at level alpha you can see that
what you have is the sum turns out to be
alpha times the number of reported
intervals and you end up controlling PFC
R so it's not very hard to see that
selective FC are actually guarantees you
a control of FC r
so now that we have a sense of what the
conditional line of work is really
trying to control let me give you let me
drive digress a bit and give you an
application in genomics and tell you
where why we need such tools to improve
our understanding of effects size
estimation in such applications so the
application that I'm going to talk about
is related to expression quantitative
trait loss i studies these are called
acute years in genomics they try to
identify regions of the genome that tell
you whether or not and how much a gene
is expressed in particular I'll be
looking at Assissi QTL mapping so
Assissi QTL mapping in particular tries
to find associations between gene
expression which is the response
variable so in terms of statistics if
you want to know what the response
variable is and what your predictors are
well the response variable is your gene
expression and the predictors are some
local genetic variants located around
the genes so what do I mean by local
genetic variants so you basically
measures snips you take a gene you look
at snips within one MB of the
transcription start site of the genes so
you look at a local window around the
gene and those constitute your
predictors so this is maybe a small
example to illustrate it so here is a
gene whose gene expression you have
recorded that's your Y or your response
and this is the small window that you
move around the gene and record all the
snips around this gene and these are
your predictors for the gene expression
of this particular gene so to give you
an idea of the data set that puts this
whole application in context so this is
GTECH it's called the GTECH data set
it's associated with a GTECH project
which was Anna Knight funded project and
you can find more details about this
data set here there are many more
details about the date
said their findings at the portal so
briefly what they look at is 44 human
tissues and there are 449 donors in all
so these are human tissues you have
collected gene expression data for
greens corresponding to 44 human tissues
and the predictors are recorded from the
genotypic information that were
collected that was collected from the
donors but you feel look at specific
human tissues like say liver or brain or
stomach etc you will notice that the
number of samples is actually even
smaller than the number for 49 that's
because each individual actually
contributes two samples for only a
subset of these 44 human tissues and not
all of the tissues further you can see
that a big challenge in this eqtl human
eqtl study is the limited samples
associated with each tissue that is
because no healthy individual is going
to give you a part of his brain to
advance science so you see just 72
samples corresponding to brain and
that's a huge limitation so from now on
maybe let me just focus on one tissue
which is liver which has 97 samples so
to cast the data into a statistical
framework we have roughly 22 K genes in
the genome corresponding to I mean
corresponding to every tissue but we are
just focusing on liver for now so we
have 22 K genes each gene so this is the
gene expression say we focused on gene G
so this gene G has gene expression
recorded as Y and it has a predictor
matrix X G which curst consists of all
the local variants around the gene so we
have this Y matrix which is a 97
dimensional vector 97 being the sample
size and this Y matrix comes with its
own matrix of predictors which are the
local variants around the gene with
number of columns being the number of
variants around that gene so this number
typically varies from 3,000 to 25,000
so that's your pea
so you can see that this can be
summarized as a multi phenotype analysis
where you have multiple phenotypes the
phenotypes being the gene expressions
associated with the 22k genes so you
have 22 km any regression problems where
you each regression problem comes with
its own response Y and a predictor
matrix X and the size of the problem
like I said n is 97 here and be like
varies from gene to gene a number
between 3,000 to 25,000 so to give you a
brief idea or a bird's eye view of how
the selection of regulatory variants
proceeds in these studies like what is
the state of art of selection it's
actually modeled as a two-stage process
so you want to find regulatory variants
that regulate the expressions of these
genes so Buster fall from 22 K genes you
try to select genes that have at least
one signal around them so each gene has
a set of local variants around it you
try to identify the genes that have some
signal around it in the first stage so
these genes are called a genes so from
22 K genes you try to select the red one
so you select a subset of these 22 K
genes which have some promise of signal
and in the second stage once you have
scanned out the genes genes you look a
bit deeply into the local variants of
these selected genes and you run
multiple regression problem for a
multivariate regression problem for each
of these genes and report variants for
corresponding to each of these selected
a genes
yes up to VP exactly so these are your
variants and you're trying to focus your
computational resources into looking
deeply around these selected agents and
report the regulatory variants that are
associated with each of these agents so
these variants that you report in the
second stage for each agent they're
called variants so this is just a bird's
eye view of how the selection is done
and this is a well-documented process
already it comes from the GTA community
and they have spent a lot of efforts in
mining in trying to document how you
mind this data to get to e variance or
regulatory variants that tell you that
hopefully our findings that that
regulate gene expressions so once you
have fine found these events the next
logical step is to try and estimate the
effect sizes of these events but of
course the catch here is that you could
have encountered potential selection
bias in having mined only about 5,000
variants from roughly 1 million variants
to begin with so there could be heavy
selection bias when you when you try to
calibrate the effect sizes of your
discovered associations so the question
that we can hopefully try and answer in
this application is that how do we
estimate the effect sizes of potential
evidence that have been discovered
through a genome-wide search over the
space of predictors
oh it's it's it's a multiple rigging
over all the regression problems yes now
to just show you I'm sure not convinced
but to show you how nice inference can
lead to completely misleading results so
this is simulation that I conducted on
the scale of G take I use the genotypic
information from the donors from the
actual G take data but I simulated the
responses on the scale of this data set
and I followed the two stage procedure
documented in their paper and I just did
knife inference trying to construct
confidence intervals and report the
coverages so the x axis here is denoting
the different signal regimes so 0 for
instance is the regime where jeans have
no two signals around them one is the
regime where jeans have exactly one
signal around them and so on and these
are the coverages of the intervals
reported for these jeans and you can see
that naive intervals are all short of
the end coverage which is 90% in this
case and they fall short by a wide
margin so we really need to do something
about such applications for sure yes
that's it just they are the two
selection stages yes it's a hierarchical
selection you select jeans are you
testing for all the variance so how I'm
gonna give you more details about that
screening States oh I did not tell you
how a jeans are really selected so for
each gene what they do is they compute
the marginal associations with all the
local variants around the gene it's a
marginal screening process and then they
do a global null hypothesis that there
is no signal around it so you can do
something like the science test or the
bonferroni to test that that particular
gene has no association with any of the
local variants
so that's based on the marginal
associations of that gene with each of
the local variants but you are not
taking into account the correlations
coming from the other variants around
that gene so it's typically done as a
marginal screening procedure because
they don't want to invest too much
computational resources at that stage
and then once you have narrowed down
your genes to your set of genes that's
where they started doing a second stage
of screening where they ran a
multivariate regression for each of the
e genes trying to identify those few
regulatory variants around each each
gene
so now uh after having talked about this
application a bit which I'll come back
in tutorial to I want to start by
discussing some first approaches to
overcoming selection bias which are
aligned along the conditional
perspective to select your inference so
I'm sure this is something that all of
you must have done at some stage of your
confirmatory analysis which is data
splitting you know that data splitting
basically overcomes selection bias you
explore your data on a random split of
the data but then decide to discard it
completely and use the remaining
fraction of your data to report
inference the question is does data
splitting control selective FCR well it
does if you were not aware of it it does
control selective FCR in the sense that
if you assume that the data points that
you conducted your selection on is
independent from the data points that
you're using in your confirmatory
analysis then this conditional
probability is just equal to the
unconditional probability and you do
control it at alpha so it's it's
certainly a very appealingly simple
procedure that does guarantee you
selective FCR control now the question
is we are completely discarding the data
that was used in selection while we do
data splitting so do we have room to
still use some leftover information from
data in the selection stage and the
other question is also can we always
afford to conduct a tour splitting like
in the equatorial example that I just
described to you where you barely see
samples in hundreds is data splitting
even a reasonable option that you have
well no because if you did two data
splitting conducting selection on say a
random 50% split of your data you end up
discovering only 4% of the e variance
that the baseline GTECH paper reports so
you don't
even find enough interesting effects
forget about inference so your only bet
would be to maybe wait for new data
points to come up and this project if
I'm not correct
I'm een if I'm not wrong has been going
on for five years now and there is no
new data set so well if you really want
to calibrate the strengths of your
discovered associations is the best bet
that you have is to wait until eternity
till you have this new data set so we
really need to think of ways of trying
to do something more reasonable than
data splitting where we have we still
discover the same findings yet have some
reasonable power when we report
inference yes so sorry what are you
comparing to here what's the four
percent of it oh so this so I was
analyzing the GTECH data set so it's a
consortium that has that is mainly aimed
at trying to find these regulatory
variants which you want to investigate
further so they don't calibrate the
effect sizes of these variants but they
do try to do hypothesis testing and find
these regulatory variants to begin with
everything you've told us that wait 96
percent of what they reported is just
you know artifact selection so they
don't actually to their defense they do
not do confidence intervals at all they
just tell you like these are some
associations that they discovered from
the data that's all so they are not
doing effect size estimates at all I
said okay 4 on top of their findings if
you were to apply some naive inferential
tools to get naive confidence intervals
they are not valid anymore so to their
defense they don't report confidence
intervals to begin with they just report
findings
so we knew maybe this is a defense
maybe this number at the bottom of your
slide is a dependence of data splitting
uh-huh sorry uh look is it obvious but
it's because yes yes but this it's
entirely consistent with the story like
maybe everything they're reporting is
noise no that's not true that's not true
larger the larger question I'm asking is
you're comparing something that you know
is statistically valid to something that
you're saying has no kind of solid
justification behind it no I barely I
mean I know let me make it clear so
already I think they say that we
discover much less than expected that's
because of this limited sample sizes so
sample sizes are barely in hundreds so
they the conjecture here is that they're
discovering less and they're limited in
their selection power already because
because of those low sample sizes I'm
saying if you further reduce that sample
size by a half then you are even losing
almost all the signals that they
discovered or maybe I don't know whether
they're signals or not but you're losing
a lot of what they were already
reporting so my guess is you are already
losing a lot of interesting stuff to
begin with so when you come to inference
it doesn't make sense because you are
not discovering anything interesting
assets so forget about the goal of
inference in this case if you're
reducing your sample size to even a half
like it that's a belabor the point but
like a priori just understand like a pro
like suppose I could or ocularly
discover exactly the
of correct genes yes would it be obvious
or should it be obvious that that number
is you know on the order of the number
of discoveries and the baseline or could
that be much smaller or much larger it's
much larger so all I'm saying is that
you're losing a lot both insulin because
if I were to do like four I'll be
reporting inference for only these four
percent of a variance right and I mean
the short answer to your question is
that I'm losing a lot of signals so I'm
not discovering enough of signals and
I'm reporting stuff for much lesser
stuff and I'm losing both power for
selection as well as inference by doing
data splitting just aligned with those
questions so in this regime report is
there any possibility or any kind of
like wet lab test
which have been for many variants like
then you have some idea of the number so
this is human eqtl and I guess this data
set as you can see is already like I
don't know if there is a second data set
on human eqtl so it's always very hard
to obtain samples for humans yes that's
um so even for this project I'm sure I
mean they should they should try to get
newer samples but they haven't so there
must be a reason for it
is collecting more samples which are
going to the south and then modifying
the locations with general editing to
pass this variant aha
so yeah I don't know if a second study
which really provides you some sort of
confirmation where you can compare the
findings across G Tech and some other
study I don't know if the second study
on human EQ tears just on this when you
double your sample size say yes at a
given level of confidence you know just
sort of naive
I know straight straightforward
asymptotics suggests that like the
effect sizes you can detect will go well
down or up depending on which direction
you're going by like what's square root
of two or something like that and ends
of the confidence intervals you mean
yeah yeah I guess that's right I mean
I'm thinking yes yes that's yes sure so
I guess
and
like given that is is it the case that
you think that like a ton of these
effects are like right above that
threshold where they're going to be
detectable with a hundred with a sample
size of n but not with the sample size
of n over two um because it's like
you're fighting for a factor of two the
sample size which makes sense when you
only know that's true but you have to
just like no matter what you do to do
the things you want to do what area yes
I mean you have some I mean you have a
buffer on like how much power you have
with these many data points that's true
but like I said like my point here was
that I'm not even talking about
inference I'm just saying that you're
losing findings to a great extent you're
just discovering four percent of what
GTECH discovers will double the sample
size reports as interesting associations
there is no theoretical guarantee on FDR
control ultimately on the E variants
that they report they try to control FDR
at the aging level for sure because once
they do those global knowledge test they
I'll describe that in details later they
pass all those global p-values through a
bh filter so they do have FDR control at
the asian level but they do not
necessarily have FDR control at the a
variant level but they try to somewhat
empirically have reasonable control of
FDR at the second stage because they try
to penalize the fact that you have
selected those genes to begin with for
which you report the a variance but they
don't have any theoretical guarantee on
FDR as far as I know so this is reaching
that maybe one possibly plausible
explanation
like you know bah and other at the arts
at controlling procedures that have
GTECH is using other things that sort of
macro signal is coming in to the process
to sort of help to reject things so even
if there are like still a decent number
of small p-value this is just a you know
possible in certain areas especially
even if there are still a decent the
first of all if you value there just
might not be enough there's some kind of
like teamwork that goes on at the age
another controller so it's um I guess
it's I mean their selection like this
election to me honestly is still very
conservative I did not try to modify the
selection procedure because that was not
my job I wanted to take like the state
of the art mining procedure that they do
and try and provide confidence intervals
and point estimates to calibrate the
effect sizes of their discovered
findings so I didn't want to change
their selection procedure per se but if
you ask me I feel it's a very
conservative procedure they first of all
they pass it through a pH threshold
which often can be quite conservative
and even in the second stage they pay a
very heavy penalty for the selection
that they did at the engine level so
they end up discovering lot less so
whatever is their state of art I feel
it's a pretty conservative selection to
begin with and maybe I should tell you
also at this point like they the belief
in the biological community is that
every gene is an e gene so it's sort of
bogus that you kind of firm you're
trying to reserve computational
resources by screening agents but the
belief there is really every gene does
have some signal around it it's just
that they don't have the power to
discover it and also in this two-stage
thing they're trying to basically you
know resolve computational sources so
that they don't have to do the search of
regulatory variants at a large scale to
begin with they try to look in deeply
for a smaller subset of genes
so now so this was the discussion on
data splitting but let's go to
conditional inference as was introduced
in dieta so let's again look at the toy
example that we were looking at so we
have a response Y and we have predictor
matrix X as selections that you just ran
last so to get an active set of
coefficients so coming to inference you
want to at this point specify a model
and a target that you want to infer
about these are the two objects that
statistical inference requires you to
specify so in little they assume a
saturated model which is basically
assuming that Y is modeled as Gaussian
with mean mu and the target they look at
is basically an adaptive Li determined
target that is obtained by refitting a
linear model to your selected subspace
of X's now for simplicity sake say I
just look at the first coordinate of
this adaptive target which is the
projection of mean mu on to the selected
subspace of X then if you were to
construct naive intervals you would look
at the OLS estimator obtained by
refitting your data to the selected
subspace of X and you would this this is
assumed to be if if you didn't have this
adaptive target you had no selection
then this would be simply Gaussian in
this setup and you have naive inference
which is valid but since now you are
inferring about this adaptive target the
question that we ask ourselves is that
how do we construct valid intervals for
the adaptive target another way of
reframing the question is what is really
the right law of this OLS estimator
since it's not Gaussian how can we
correctly calibrate its law and this
answer was provided by Lee atta it's
based on two key observations one the
selection by lasso is equivalent to a
set of polyhedral constraints so you can
describe the selection by lasso as a set
of affine constraints on your response
why
and the second key observation was
looking at the law of your knife
statistic which was this thing which
without any selection was just Gaussian
so you try to look at the law of your
knife statistic condition on selection
which is the set of polyhedral
constraints and in addition to that you
also condition on noise and statistics
which correspond to nuisance parameters
so you condition on this PE tupper Y
which is basically conditioning on all
directions orthogonal to your direction
of interest ETA so once you look at this
election event this law happens to be a
univariate truncated Gaussian law and
this is based on the observation that if
you write out the selection event of
Lhasa which is the set of polyhedral
constraints and you condition
additionally on the newest institutions
of interest ETA prime Y is actually
restricted between array so you can see
that ETA prime Y is just restricted
between gamma minus and gamma plus and
these are functions of the statistics
that you conditioned on or basically you
nuisance statistics that correspond to
nuisance parameters so you have your
polyhedra lemma as a result of which the
law that you're looking at happens to be
a univariate truncated Gaussian law and
these gamma minus and gamma plus can be
computed explicitly so this is what is
dubbed as polyhedral lemma in leotta
now let's just revisit the toy example
of law so that we have been looking at
it's the same example so now I report
coordinate wise inference so I look at
this target and a report inference for
the first coordinate of it the second
coordinate third coordinate and so on
and like I said the pivot that I use is
this truncated Gaussian pivot from Lee
at all let's see if the intervals now
that we construct based only at all if
they're valid or not so this is the
table that I had so we can see that if
we target at 90
sent coverage the coverage of the Li at
all intervals based on the strong heated
Gaussian pivot is pretty good it's close
to the 90 percent target so clearly it
gives us a neat pivot which is very easy
to compute it's just a truncated
Gaussian law you can compute it and it
gives us coverage guarantees so the
question now is do we really need to
look beyond lis at all yes coverage
guarantees like yes it's like 90% or
above why should it be I mean the target
is 90 percent so this is I am
empirically computing the coverage right
I'm repeating the experiment 50 times
and I'm computing the coverage so it's
close enough to the 90 put like anything
to 2 or 3% plus or minus is good enough
it's just empirical coverage actually
gonna be my question what's the sort of
confidence interval does coverage
numbers like what am i covering or no
using each of these coverage numbers
yeah so these are confidence some
underlying proportion which we hope this
point 9 yes they're all like
consistently right around 87%
I mean point nine point nine is the
asymptotic value so it's sort of like in
a point I'm a hole with as P and n go to
infinity no no no no no these are exact
intervals like you're sorry you're
repeatedly so these coverages are for
the adaptive target that I just showed
you and these are coverages on an
average reported over all the selected
intervals that you report and this is
this is something that I compute
empirically so I construct these
confidence intervals see the proportion
of them not covering the true underlying
parameter or covering the true
underlying parameter as in this case and
it's close to 90% that's what you expect
if the pivot is valid yes it's a finite
coverage guarantee there is no asymptote
x y or any at all is a finite cover
guaranteed it's exactly Gaussian like
I'm generating my data from a Gaussian
model as I described to you in such a
case Li at all is exact and it provides
you finite coverage guarantees there is
no there is no asymptotics here this
question is it if it's actually supposed
to be providing 90% coverage it seems a
bit weird that they're all providing 87%
coverage I'm saying they're supposed to
provide like 90% coverage because it
seems to contradict such a thing
well yeah 50 replicates like maybe you
if I sorry 50 yes 50 times the number of
selected intervals right so I'm actually
reporting 50 times mod e interval so if
in the first round I select 5 then I'm
reporting 5 intervals so it's 50 times
the average like number of selected
intervals that I've this is not Monte
Carlo all right they want their Monte
Carlo estimate of the true 90% right if
you only did it oh yes yes yes yes maybe
if you use the same noise for zero why
are they so close to each other they're
not also tonight let me tell you I use
the Selective inference package in our
so feel free to contact the users I
don't endorse this method really and
that's what's coming in part two of the
tutorial why I hate this and why there
is much more beyond this so that was
coming in the second slide so I neither
endorsed the packet it's not something
that I coded so feel free to contact Rob
tips Ronnie Ryan and I don't know who
else Josh Johnson Johnson also doesn't
endorse this by the way but anyways I
mean I think they're fairly close enough
so statisticians were happy if they're
like you know three percent off like I
mean maybe if I do fifty more runs maybe
the these numbers
look a bit up down I don't know like
some of them might be close to 90% so I
don't know if this is really a concern
for me that they're like pretty tightly
concentrated or are they they do but I
don't have an explanation for it I feel
the intervals are exact and they should
give me good enough coverage
no there is no approximation here it's
an exact pivot and my data generative
mechanism is also a Gaussian Jett data
generative mechanism so it should be
exact here because
okay so the question that I said is that
do we need to look beyond Liotta so I
showed you coverages of these intervals
but a very annoying part of me at all
intervals is that they can be very long
and associated with really low
statistical power so now I'm going to
show you the average length of these
intervals and if you actually call the
Selective inference package in R and
look at the proportion of intervals that
are also infinitely long so this row
tells you the proportion of intervals
that happen to be infinitely long and
this gives you the average length of the
intervals that are not infinite so you
can see that they're terribly long
intervals they don't seem very stable in
that sense and there is a new paper in
2018 by Lieb where he has shown that the
expected length of the lis at all
intervals are actually in is actually
infinity so so like I said the takeaway
here is that little intervals can be
very long yes why so I just ran the
Selective inference package you know and
this is the proportion of intervals that
happen to be infinitely long that's all
I'm saying in my experiment I gave you
the actual data generative mechanism
repeated it reported intervals these are
the average lengths of the intervals
which are not infinitely long and these
many intervals happen to be infinitely
long
maybe it's nothing about this so you
think it's about the code but it could
be possible like you know that it just
happens to be a rare selection event and
that's what we see in the italic when
you are approaching the selection
boundary your intervals just happen to
be very unstable and infinitely long so
let's maybe see an explanation of okay
so this is not a slide on the exon
explaining why little intervals can be
infinitely long but this is data
splitting for the same experiment and I
mean I have 500 data points so I ran ran
the lasso and 250 data points and
reported intervals for the remaining 250
data points and we see that data
splitting has also pretty good coverage
as expected because it overcomes
selection bias and the lengths are much
shorter than yet also really like is
Liat up buying us anything here the
lengths are much longer so let's try and
understand what's going on here so it's
a concept of leftover information that
can tell us like give us an idea why
little intervals can be so poorly
behaved and isn't that Li at all really
isn't telling us much beyond sample
splitting let's see so let's look at a
very simple example forget about
regression you have just a single
Gaussian data from a Gaussian
distribution which has mean parametrized
by mu your selection is just a threshold
election event you report if Y is
greater than lambda and we at all will
look at the conditional law of Y given Y
greater than lambda now to compare it
with data splitting let's just let's
just double the sample size let's have
two observations and we report about me
if y1 is greater than lambda and y2 is
greater than lambda so let's plot the
leftover information in the data from
selection with the parameter values and
we see that V at all you can see that
sample
splitting always has information equal
to one because that's the variance you
would base your inference on the law of
white to unconditional law by 2 which is
Gaussian it is variance 1 so that is the
leftover information that you have
whereas in case of Liat are the leftover
information can go to 0 when your
parameter values become more and more
negative so as your parameter actual
signals become more and more negative
that's when your selection becomes rarer
and rarer and after a point you are just
left with no leftover information for
inference so we can see that little is
certainly better than data splitting in
this regime where you're actually using
all the information that you had in your
data and selection and you have no
leftover information for inference but
it's doing better than splitting in this
regime so so what is it like principally
how can we do better than both lis and
splitting yes the leftover information
is actually when you write out the
conditional law or the law in which so
in lis at all it's a conditional law a Y
condition on Y greater than lambda in
case of data splitting is just the
unconditional love Y to write which is
just a Gaussian so leftover information
is basically the Fisher information that
you compute based on that law so once
you have that law you can take double
derivatives and compute the Fisher
information or the expected Fisher
information I'm missing what I'm missing
I think is why leftover information
having lots of leftover information is a
good thing
I mean intuitively like what your so
what sample splitting was doing was
discarding the data that completely that
you used in selection but conditioning
in some ways is trying to still use some
information in that data that was left
over from selection so if you if you
have intuitively just think about it the
more the leftover information that you
have from selection stage you can use it
in
friends and get more powerful inference
I think the intuition is fine I think
the problem is many of us don't know
they formal expression of what it is
yeah the expression is is Fisher
information so the law that you base
your inference upon like I said in case
of Lee at all it's a conditional law you
compute the Fisher information that
quantifies the leftover information that
you have for inference not I don't think
not necessarily not necessarily is it
major derailment if you just wrote it
out for this simple experiment on the
board I know of course I know I mean I
like I said it's
so in this case uh I mean your law has
saved y-
right
so the log likelihood that I have in lis
at all is the log likelihood as a
function of MU is this quantity and my
leftover information this is the
so if you take the double derivative of
this sum log likelihood that's your
observed Fisher information right that's
what I'm plotting here so all I'm saying
is that that observed Fisher information
goes to zero as your parameter value
becomes more and more negative I think
I'm missing is like I understand when
use information sort of informally as an
English word like more information is
good huh you don't see where what I'm
asking is sort of like why is Fisher
information is the thing that we want
that we care about yeah quite like why
this specific measure of information you
know there are various connections to
sort of minimal variance unbiased
estimation and things like that that
that theory like I've seen it I how much
but I remember online isn't that much of
a bit like different information kind of
like as the name suggests it's it's
quantifying the information in the law
that you're basing your inference apart
right it's it's how informated your is
your inferential law about the parameter
that you're inferring about that's what
Fisher information quantifies first
interstitials I don't know if I have a
better answer for it is it there's a
theory of asymptotics it says that but
really the best estimators possible
depend very precisely on the fishing
and by us I mean in the classical regime
just period any estimator asymptotically
fish information governs its baby-faced
asymptotically on fire no no no just
period like it automatically conditions
otherwise some Dunnigan normal fish
information theory programs like the
first time von Mises type stuff yes
low-cost out of normality but it's just
there's a theory that says in all
classical problems at some tonic Peter
described very precisely how well
estimators how positive minimal nope
very oh no no no no estimator period any
estimator at all nothing about
unbiasness no no but just okay but no no
on the word how well how well it may be
an answer could be grammar Rao or lower
bound also like if your that's this is
too much of a question I'm sorry I know
no I mean I appreciate the questions but
like again I get why I get why I like
it's imperative straight quarter level
comment your information is good the
women morally gentleman as n goes to
infinity it the best possible estimator
that you could have yeah and then
supremum over all parameters theta that
are within basically so theta 0 is your
true parameter basically something like
1 + square root and of this true
parameter expectation under the
distribution of theta of your loss of
square root and
estimator - pictures parameter this is
bigger than or equal to expectation
that's that's the sense in which Fisher
information sir characterized it here at
going around around two feet in the
neighborhood of a particular zero
what do your estimation so now that the
expression blue over here is some
expectation of you might like I mean if
you take the double derivative that's
that's for your vice so you don't even
have to take the expectation based on
this law like here I'm sorry Adam you're
busy ourselves this is we're not
necessarily doing as some type of things
here even across today you know this
your information has many beautiful as
an asymptotic or yeah it's sort of the
right asymptotic you know summary of
what how much information there is
however usually we're just using one
observation of a truncated joshan to
construct a confidence interval and I
don't know of any real pounds that you
could get on the length of the
confidence interval from like a Fisher
information type thing I guess maybe in
meta-analysis were you know accumulating
many truncated estimates at this board
like it right selection adjusted
meta-analysis
and you would have some interesting
implication there the way that we're
typically using this in I don't think
give you I think the main takeaway is if
you kind of understand Fisher
information is really just telling you
how information or inference for the
parameter that you're trying to infer
about how informated is that law and
it's sort of a quantification that we as
statisticians use
so clearly we see that like my main
point here was that Li at all basically
somewhat uses all the information in
your data that was up in selection as
your parameter value becomes more and
more negative as a result of which if
you construct intervals corresponding to
this regime they become infinitely long
because you don't have any power at that
stage left for inference now so the
question is splitting really doesn't
look at all of the data and selection
it's it's kind of it's winning in this
regime because it's somewhat not looking
at all of your data it's just looking at
a part of your data that's why it does
better than lis it up but there is this
fundamental problem in splitting that
it's not it's discarding the data
completely and hence in this regime it's
Li at all which is in the other regime
it's Li at all which is winning because
it's somehow getting leveraging on the
fact that it's still using some
information left over in the data from
selection so how can we get the best of
both the worlds both splitting and
leotta
and a simple answer is carving so why
not we combine the idea of splitting and
Lyoto that is we use not all of the data
during selection but just why one for
selection but now we just don't discard
it completely but still try to use some
leftover information from it in
inference so we try to look at the law
of y1 and y2 conditional on y1 greater
than lambda so we are using a fraction
of the data for selection not looking at
all of the data in the selection state
but still we are using the conditioning
idea of little to try and utilize
whatever information is left over to get
the advantages of conditional so this is
a plot of again the leftover information
of the Fisher information of the
conditional law so this is what I've
added which is the Fisher information
from the carved law and you can see that
it dominates both splitting and little
mostly so it's probably the right thing
to do which gives us a best of both
words both
splitting and little and as I view it
it's fundamentally the right approach to
go about so if you want to have
inference with some reasonable par as
your end goal don't look at all of your
data reserve some of your data for
inference but at the same stage we can
condition on the part of the data that
we use for selection to give optimal
inference so the takeaways from this
part of the tutorial that I hope you
took is I don't want to view data mining
really as a bad thing to do it's not
data snooping there are like efforts of
large communities to find to explore
data and get some structure in data so
we want to leverage upon those findings
and do a confirmatory analysis to
somewhat give confidence intervals and
reasonable point estimates with some
statistical guarantees at the end of the
day secondly I talked about this
conditional approach to overcome bias
hopefully I conveyed you the guarantees
of conditional approach and I give you
some first approaches to overcome
selective bias which was data splitting
and Liat are and we saw maybe I didn't
convince all of you but maybe if you get
at least an intuitive understanding of
why Liat are can lead to infinitely long
intervals because it doesn't have the
conditional law once we use all of the
data in selection in some regimes as
selection becomes rarer and rarer it
doesn't have any more left over
information for inference and in the
second part of the tutorial though I
already gave you the answer that carving
is the right way to go I'll talk about
it more in details and what can be the
technical challenges in providing carved
inference and how do we overcome them at
the moment so that would be in part 2 of
the tutorial
propose that we resume at 10:30 as
scheduled subject US nuclear giving
enough of it
oh no I'm good